begin with President Trump who is poised
to take action today that could test our
two hundred and thirty year old system
of checks and balances in government
he's expected to declare a national
emergency at the us-mexican border so he
can reallocate federal money to build a
border wall this morning the president
is due to sign a budget deal passed
overwhelmingly by Congress that will
prevent another government shutdown it
includes only about one-quarter of the
border security funding the president
demanded so he plans to act on his own
to find the rest
well CBS News confirms the President
does plan to spend eight billion dollars
on that wall three and a half billion
will come from the Defense Department's
military construction budget another two
and a half million will be diverted from
the Pentagon's drug interdiction program
and six hundred million dollars will
come from the Treasury Department's drug
forfeiture fund Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with a move that is sure to
be challenged in court Nancy good
morning to you good morning well
declaring a national emergency
essentially means that the president can
gather the funds that he wants for a
border wall without the approval of
Congress Democrats accuse him of
fear-mongering to get what he wants and
even some Republicans worried that this
creates a dangerous precedent declaring
a national emergency would be a lawless
act a gross abuse of the power of the
presidency the decision sent shockwaves
through Capitol Hill will trump ever
look our soldiers and veterans in the
eye and tell them that it is they who
will pay for this wall of waste of
course not the president has unilateral
powers to declare a national emergency
which enables him to seize property and
redirect funds from other projects
without congressional approval it is
typically reserved for natural disasters
or major crises like the September 11th
attacks or foreign interference in u.s.
elections President Trump has been
hinting at it for weeks if they can't do
it I will declare a national emergency I
have the absolute right to do GOP
leaders who had been lukewarm on the
idea suddenly had a change of heart I've
indicated to him that I'm
prepare I've got to support the national
emergency declaration House Minority
Leader Kevin McCarthy wrote we face a
humanitarian and national security
crisis at the border that must be
addressed but Democrats point to customs
and border statistics that show illegal
border crossings are near a 20-year low
do you still plan to file a legal
challenge that's an option and we'll
review our options
the president's allies argue he was left
with little choice after a five-week
partial shutdown and three-week
congressional negotiation failed to
produce funding he had demanded for his
proposed border wall but some
Republicans worried the move could
create new options for a future
Democratic president
speaker Pelosi pointed to the parkland
shooting and gun violence as an example
that's a national emergency
why don't you declare that emergency mr.
president I wish you would but a
Democratic president can do that
Democratic commit president can declare
emergencies as well even if the
president does sign this emergency
declaration all those funds might not go
to a wall right away that's because he
is expected to face an array of legal
challenges from House Democrats and
others the president Gale insists that
the law is 100% on his side well we're
not surprised to hear that from the
White House but this conversation
certainly continues Thank You Nancy